je m'appelle magnéto ce qui est je suis
le bassiste du trio ses manies
je m'appelle en tuyaux ferme aux emmy
des eaux je suis le guitariste de ses
manies
je suis yann garot je suis le batteur du
trio jazz slimani
issus de trois générations différentes
ces musiciens composent le trio selmani
depuis 2015 propres aux inspirations
rock folk jazz ou encore blues dévoile
son premier album atterri comme leur vie
chacun peut se retrouver dans la musique
que j'ai crié n'est pas spécifique
vraiment à un mouvement mais à
des multi mouvement je dirais qu'ils
permettent justement une ouverture sur
n'importe quel public n'apporte que
souvent on dit au dessus du jazz donc je
n'aime pas voilà c'est l'idée que se
font les gens et donc j'essaye à un
essai avec notre musique devant montrer
que bach le jazz c'est pas que ça
chantait revente au groupe sal la
musique prime mais pour autant les
mélodies raconte toujours une histoire
que ce soit 6 et n'y voir que ce soit
strates que ce soit l'élégance de
l'arbre aussi et milo c'est des choses
qui partent d'une idée d'une idée d'un
principe ou d'une histoire c'est
beaucoup des sensations j'ai pas là on
rejoint le côté un peu je pense
charnelle de la musique quoi c'est ce
que ça nous évoque et après moi je
trouve ça aussi intéressant d'avoir un
immense pour ça qu'on a décidé le mettre
dans le livre d'avoir la clé de lecture
de pouvoir après les réécouter en
pensant à oui d'accord en fait emilio
penser aux aux migrants par exemple en
écrivant ce morceau et ça donne un peu
un jour nouveau morceau quand on écoute
venue de maurepas et de versailles ces
trois musiciens ont sorti un clip le 18
janvier de la chanson she's anywhere
ndaw
2 vous
on a fait ce clip à maurepas
donc à côté du bassin de la courance
dans une belle campagne là bas
le trio taïmani se produira mardi 1er
février au sunset sunside à paris ils
seront également en concert à maurepas
le vendredi 9 décembre
[Musique]